The solution for x is positive three halves. Nice work if you found this
answer. I really hope you've gained some steam in solving logarithmic
equations. We'll start by multiplying these two arguments together to get the
log base 6 of 2x squared, plus 7x, equals log base 6 of 15. We get this
argument by multiplying x times 2x, which is 2x squared, and x by positive 7,
which is positive 7x. Now we can set these two arguments equal to one another.
We'll subtract 15 from both sides, to get our quadratic set equal to zero.
Factoring this quadratic, will have the two factors of 2x minus 3, and x plus
5. We set each factor equal to zero, and then, we solve for the values of x.
So, x can equal three halves, or one and a half or x can equal negative 5. We
want to be cautious and make sure these answers check in our original solution.
Since we have log base 6 of x, we know that x equals negative 5 will not be a
solution. We can't take the logarithm of a negative number. This solution
doesn't work, so our only answer is x equals three halves.